vous ne respectez donc rien c'est un
titre qui annonce le trait de caractère
communs à tous les écrivains présents de
ce soir donc sur le plateau
d'apostrophés 21h40
ils seront les invités donc de bernard
pivot et puis à 23 heures bien que
jean-philippe nous proposera à son
ciné-club le ciné-club de l'été avec un
film de jean louis trintignant et oui
vous saviez que jean-louis train
peut-être que jean louis trintignant
était scénariste dialoguiste et
réalisateur son premier film il l'a
réalisé en 1972 avec jacques dufilho
dans le rôle principal
il s'agit d'une journée bien remplie
donc que ce soit dans le ciné club le
ciné-club d'été à partir de 23 heures
voilà j'espère que tous ses rendez-vous
veux bien vous plairont et vous feront
passer une agréable soirée en compagnie
de patricia le sieur que vous
retrouverez tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure aussi dans un petit moment où
pourrait jouer le jeu des chiffres et
des lettres
mais auparavant via quelques petits
moments où nous allons passer ensemble
et avec quelques images très rigolote